welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
titled emerging drug combinations
evolution from preclinical discovery to
clinical development it's my pleasure to
introduce to you dr. coyote Shaw
dr. Shaw received her PhD in molecular
pharmacology from the University of the
Pacific in Stockton California currently
she's a postdoctoral research scholar at
the University of California at San
Francisco for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
my name is Antonina pavlenko and I will
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Lavery's lab reads is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
all the process to obtain your credits
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Ciotti Shah I will now
turn the presentation over to her hello
everyone my name is Cathy Shah and I'm
today going to give a keynote
presentation on emerging the drug
combination how it evolves from prenatal
discovery to clinical development so for
this purpose I would like to give an
outline of my job first I will be
talking about why precision medicine is
so important in truth discovery however
it's been long time that we have been
practicing the precision medicine
were the better drugs but there are some
inadequacies that exist and I would
highlight what are those and how we see
that the limited therapeutic responses
or innate resistance is the main
bottleneck of being successful in truly
practicing the precision medicine so the
way we take our approaches we design the
rational combination therapy first to
defend the therapeutic response and use
that as a method to the therapeutic
resistance so in the preclinical a
laboratory setting we think that this is
a very successful method and we have
shown this over again and again so I
will put examples of that and at the end
I will even discuss how it can be
integrated into the clinical trials and
what is the current landscape and future
future vision for the combination
therapy in the clinic all right so let's
just get started
traditionally the drug discovery process
is made to have one size fit all we have
a patient population that has very
different genotype or different
phenotype and mainly to be earlier
clinical trials especially the original
trials 15 one 13 cancels four decide
that most of the patient gets all the
drug disregarding their genetic or
philippic underlying cause
so what that causes that was an adverse
event in some patient some patient
population had no benefit of the drug
and some patient had benefit so the
precision medicine is all about how we
can identify the patient population that
derives the benefit of of the therapy
and the way we do this is to practice a
stratified medicine by identifying the
genomic or a molecular marker definitely
these patient population and stratifying
the patient population with that and a
practicing integrating a companion
diagnostic biomarker with it to identify
which population can get
benefit from this therapies and the
classic example of this is in case of a
breast cancer population 65% our patient
population have a molecular marker
called estrogen receptor so these
patients likely to derive been a benefit
from the drugs that are designed to
inhibit the estrogen receptor 25% of the
patient population displayed her to
positivity and these patient will derive
a benefit hard to targeted therapies and
so although we understand the genomic
ideologue etiology or genetic minka
copies we don't have a classical
molecular marker linked to this
population and those are all triple
negative populations so overall this is
a very well-known practice in precision
medicine to identify the patient
population based on the marker and hence
the precision medicine ensures the
delivery of right intervention to the
right patient at the right time so to
take this further we design the
mechanism based therapy so I will talk
about estrogen receptors in this case
estrogen receptor when binds to estrogen
leads to a dimerization this recruits
the activator at the targeted estrogen
receptor regulatory element and it leads
to increase in the proliferation and
ultimately the breast cancer growth so
this is a genetic driver estrogen
receptor is a genetic driver in the in
the case of breast cancer in some
patients
that's why selective estrogen receptor
modulars were designed so that it binds
to the estrogen receptor and leaves to
recruitment of current pressure and this
further suppresses the gene
transcription a downstream gene
transcription and hence leads to
inhibition of cell growth in being as in
the case of breast cancer so that is why
we practice the mechanism based cancer
therapy so this leads to a question that
then we should be really
successful for the patient we identified
that are having a positive a molecular
markers such as estrogen receptors so is
that the case if you look at you know
get over here um most of the drugs that
were identified for that particular
thought molecular target or a given
indication listed here we see that the
patient have modest benefit meaning that
ten progression-free survival is not
longer and their overall objective
response in the patient is also limited
almost no patient over here received
like 100% pure indicated by the violet
bars over here this leads to a question
that why we see this reduction in the
objective response rate and what
clinical factors informs us about this
so the major way to identify this is to
look at the clinical trials that are
conducted for these therapies and almost
this is a generic form of a waterfall
curve of the patient whose tumors are
measured after done giving the standard
therapy for a given time line what you
can see that some of the patient on the
left side indicated in the red and black
bar they do not respond meaning that
they go on to have a progressive disease
some patient however do respond but they
almost never have a complete response
very very few patient in a clinical
trial displayed complete response
meaning that their tumors are completely
eradicated so the main limitation on why
we are not successful in practicing the
precision medicine is because a the
problem with innate resistance then
despite having a molecular target
despite knowing their genetic makeup and
despite giving the right drug that we
don't understand why these patient have
innate resistance and although they do
they do respond they never receive a
response may have a residual disease or
incomplete response so these two are the
main two bottleneck of being successful
in our drug
every process and in case of a tamoxifen
we can use this as a standard example
and I didn't try to identify what what
are teachers that are happening in these
tamoxifen sensitive cells so most of the
sir estrogen receptor-positive cells
when they received tamoxifen they
undergo cell cell death and most of the
tumor shrink and that can be indicated
over here in the cell culture you can
see that in presence of mcf7 which is
the estrogen receptor positive cells if
we give them new treatment B cells prove
in presence of estrogen they grow even
faster and tamoxifen which is the
estrogen receptor in a blocker it
prevents the transcription of classical
estrogen retroactive genes and you see
that the tamoxifen is effective in
inducing cell death in these are
reducing cell proliferation in these
mcf7 positive cells however there are
tamoxifen innate resistance cells these
cells are known to have a growth factor
signaling which is the center around a
KT and the le unnie's pathway when these
pathways are activated in these estrogen
receptor positive cells these patients
do not wear I to drive any benefit from
tamoxifen treatment meaning that it is a
innate resistance so we have these cell
line models to test this end the model
for that is they are seven five one when
you give them no treatment he'll grow as
similar as in presence of estrogen as
well as in terms of tamoxifen meaning
that now despite having estrogen
receptors the tamoxifen has no efficacy
on these cells maybe because they never
hired or a guilty activity so we wanted
to study this further and these are the
publishing results in molecular cancer
research and what we identified we
looked at different atti so far and we
found that in 81 and 83 are
significantly associated with the
patient who recur have a recurrent tumor
and
and a negative one and akt three
isoforms were also correlated with
higher aggressiveness these patients had
more chances that they will feel there
will be a relapse upon therapy and they
will have even more aggressive tumors so
clearly a guilty signaling plays an
important role in this to study this in
detail what we did is we designed a
particular cell culture cell line models
to study this in detail and then we take
our mcf-7 cells which are classical
estrogen receptor positive cells what
I've shown that those form beautifully
took tamoxifen when we overexpress 81
and 83 and so geniusly
we see that that's a downstream
activation indicated by higher
phosphatase k3 beta activity and these
two these cell lines been interrupted in
xenograph
we see that in presence of tamoxifen
they grow even faster in mcf7 cell
despite there being estrogen receptor
positive cells so we can use this and
identify what is a contribution of AKG
in the one English and on second
response we took this study further to
identify how different ATT isoforms is
an important rule so I have already
shown you in presence of M C in mcf7
cells tamoxifen reduces the cell
proliferation when we have this
exogenously get you over expressing
cells you can see that our tamoxifen
induces growth in case of the akt1 as
well as in presence of a kp3 this is
very similar behavior to estrogen
receptor negative cell lines such as
mdaa in 4 6 8 which is new to have
higher a 81 and 3 I so far and mbmb 2 3
1 which is known to have a higher akt 3
and I have already shown you that camels
if an insensitive cell lines that also
has estrogen receptor but has no
advocacy in jumps for the tamoxifen
responses so clearly this suggests that
a kt signaling case an important
and specifically 81 any 83 as forms are
main contributors in limiting the
therapeutic benefit of the tamoxifen so
this leads us to ask a big question in
the field can we identify differentially
rewired signaling network that alters
tamoxifen responses can we also design
the synergistic combination therapy to
defund the tamoxifen responses and will
there be any clinical benefit to
tamoxifen resistant patient specially
identifying a surrogate resistance and
identifying the secondary drug target
that helps us to overcome the resistance
so to do this we perform a gene
expression analysis we specially use the
microarray technology in Inc 83
overexpressing cells which were treated
with jamaats mcf7 cells which are
treatment sensitive and what we found is
the top deep regulated genes indicated
over here in red and Tom downregulated
genes indicated in green in the takt 3
mcf7 panels when we studied this further
and validated to PCR say we found that
our changes were very similar and we
were able to validate what we see in our
gene expression analysis Oh
moreover when we take this gene
signature which were operated in a KD 3
tamoxifen treated cells we found that
having higher expression predicts a
reversal of the patients in the patient
database using on combine and keep a
plot or page acept
also the downregulated genes when they
their expression is high that predicts
that the patient have better survival
rate meaning that our signature has
significance in terms of governing how
these patients respond on tamoxifen
treatment and when we looked at the
cellular network our cellular pathways
that these genes try we found that
a cell proliferation as well as the cell
motility function was governed by a very
interesting gene called RR m 2 and we
took this further in our study so I will
introduce what is tribal nucleotide
reductase every cells have the
ribonucleotide phosphate that needs to
be converted into g oxy reliable
nucleotide phosphate and this reaction
is catalyzed by an enzyme called
ribonucleotide reductase this enzyme
activity is required for DNA synthesis
and ribonucleotide reductase in Sun has
a two units the large unit are m1
indicated here in three and a smaller
unit are two indicated in orange this
complex itself function is a catalytic
enzymes for of providing them the DNA
synthesis and hence this is a very
important step in any cellular growth or
in any cancer proliferation
rm2 activity increases at the late jibon
and early s-phase interface booker that
sweatery synthesis starts also if you
look at the literature evidence there
are various evidence indicating the
importance of this error and two enzyme
in governing the genomic integrity and
DNA repair it's been shown that the SCF
cyclin f ubiquitin ligase the monster
rm2 degradation and if it is responsible
for creating a genomic stability however
when there is a Jeannot Jeannot toxic
stress or there is a DNA damage that
occurs rm2 expression is stabilized and
hence the dntp production is increased
and the cell is likely to repair the DNA
so this shows that our lm2 complex has
an important role in governing the
genomic integrity and in case of a
chemotherapy induced DNA damage this
plays an important role because if the
cells are able to efficiently repair the
DNA
they are most likely to avoid the cell
death in case of cancer and hence rm2
could be one of the potential target
it's been also shown that suppression of
nucleotide metabolism by removing the
rm2 is also responsible for antigen
induced senescence it's been shown that
our rm2 via the e to F mediated
transcription factor is responsible for
inducing the senescence in when you have
over expression of oncogenes such as
Russ but if you if you su super
physiologically Express the RM to these
cells are able to undergo the
transformation and cause cancer so it
can overcome the oncogene induced
senescence and hence rm2 plays an
essential role in governing the response
to most of the chemotherapy drugs but
how that is related to estrogen receptor
and we wanted to establish this
population so be examining the different
database submitted in the on command to
look at the expression of our rm2
between estrogen receptor-positive and
estrogen receptor negative cells and
what we found that in estrogen receptor
negative tumors are rm2 expression was
highly expressed so as in our cell line
models
mcf7 being our sensitive cell line model
which has higher amount of estrogen
receptor alpha indicated over here by
higher here alpha 66 handle orm to level
but other cell line models which exhibit
diminish responds to tamoxifen such as
akt1
883 m TN because it's 8 gr 7 PI bond and
MDMA to 3-1 they know to have a higher
expression of other m 2 and they have
diminished
expression of classical estrogen
receptor alpha 66 indicating that that
there would be a some correlation
between estrogen receptor expression and
our game to expression to expand this
we took a panel of estrogen
receptor-positive cell lines which are
indicated over human by presence of
estrogen receptor alpha 66 only the cr7
5-1 which had which I showed you earlier
in stem of Japan in sensitive cell line
shown to have higher rm2 expression and
impress in case of estrogen receptor
negative cell lines in this panel of six
different cell line we found that all of
them and hide and they were estrogen
receptor negative me so clearly
indicating that our lm2 and estrogen
receptor negativity correlates and
whenever you have probably these cell
lines have diminished expression of
estrogen receptor alpha and n spoon yet
hence won't get any benefit from
tamoxifen so can we use this rm2 as a
target to enhance the response to
tamoxifen and to do that what we did is
we performed the SI rning knockdown in a
panel of cell lines mcf7 insensitive and
to do and the other cell line panels /
rm2 hi and we used two different si RNA
and what shown over here in akt1 and
Katie three over expressing some lines
that we were able to successfully not
down the expression of other m2 and what
we can see is that NC have seven cells
knocking down P and treating with
tamoxifen in mcf-7 cells diminished E
cell proliferation but not in other akt
all cells then you treat then with the
other end to si are any there was no
effect on cell proliferation
however you know here that when you are
knock down the other and to and treat
them with tamoxifen they were able to
induce that was a reduction in cell
proliferation with brrm to knock down an
tamoxifen treatment so if you compare
the red and
but there is significant reduction when
you remove the honoring tool from the
equation so this is a very interesting
observation but as we know that certain
SI rna-based
studies has to be validated using a
pharmacological inhibitor and hence we
use the die dogs which is a
ribonucleotide reductase inhibitor whose
molecular structure is given over here
this was done in collaboration with a
company called molecules for health
invented by dr. Alfred Harvard who made
who synthesizes Leibel nucleotide
reductase inhibitor and is mainly
response has multifaceted action it's
mainly used as antiviral it has
antibacterial property it mainly works
by anti-inflammatory and it also reduces
the NF kappa-b mediated signaling this
drug is mainly used in terms of for
sickle cell anemia and in case of a
certain or T cell malignancies but its
role in breast cancer was not new
there are clinical trials that was done
initially to identify the activity of
the drug patient for able to tolerate
six gram of Tron but this drug as a
single agent had more advocacy into it
is a tyrosine radical scavenger and
hence it serve as a nd implementer II
and it destabilizes the RM to e subunit
of tribal nucleotide reductase enzyme so
we use this in our in vitro as well as
our in vivo or model of tamoxifen
resistance in case of her mcf-7 cells
just the control treatment we see that
is a cell proliferation tamoxifen was
able to was sensitive only in mcf-7
cells but not in these AKA
hai cells die dogs as a single agent
have no efficacy but the combination did
a much better job in video single self
purification in this in vitro model
similarly when we take our a KD 3 model
and
xenograft talked of it we see that the
tamoxifen induced even more pronounced
earth tumor growth of these tumors and
dialogues as a single agent had no época
see but the combination did much better
job in reducing the tumor volume in
these 818 key overexpressing
mcf-7 cells which is our in vivo model
for tamoxifen resistance so clearly this
suggests that the dye dogs do have a
significant benefits in patients and we
wanted to even understand how the what
expression of rm2 confers resistance so
to do that we did what we did is we took
our mcf-7 which is estrogen receptor
positive and tamoxifen sensitive cell
line but express them two different
constructs of rm2 and what we see over
here is that there is a colony from the
colony formation as saying that in the
MC of 7/7 tamoxifen is able to reduce
the cell proliferation is shown in the
panel 1 but when the overexpressed the
other end - there is no reduction in the
tamoxifen tamoxifen loses its effect and
when you combine them with the tamoxifen
and I dogs at a given dose we see that
this is able to reduce the cell
proliferation significantly and this is
also indicated the reason why we see the
SIP synergies because the you know I
believe low tide reductase enzyme
activity of these cells when the
overexpress rm2 is significantly higher
but die docks reduces this
ribonucleotide reductase activity much
efficiently and these cells now don't
have any GNA to proliferate and hence we
see this synergistic effect
Oh clearly indicating that how our m3
plays an important role in cell
proliferation is up against self to
study this further we took our
overexpressing cell lines and try to
identify by performing
cancer cancer killing us very important
area to identify which pathways that
other and who drives and what we found
is when we overexpress rm2 there is a
significant in increase in NF kappa-b
and hip on alpha activity and then we
treat these are mTOR expressing cells
with die dogs we see the complete
reduction in these NF kappa-b activity
indicating that by inhibiting or
directing it also restore the p53
signaling and when we look at the effect
on cell motility are just over
expressing our rm2 increases distal
motility and decrease the percentage
open area but can we treat them with die
dogs this this was able to inhibit the
cell motility and cell migration as well
as cell invasion so next we wanted to
identify
rm2 plays an important role in the
acquired resistance is then you have the
estrogen receptors positive cells most
of the cells that respond to tamoxifen
but what happens in the clinic when the
patient undergoes long term Johnson
treatment therapy is they have certain
mutations amplification or epigenetic
changes that are occurring in that tumor
and that renders them ultimately
irresponsive to tamoxifen and we wanted
to identify if rm2 has any important
role in in this setting as well so to
determine the clinical relevance of rm2
expression what we did is we again went
back to on component and identify a
patient database which had which one
treated with tamoxifen and indicated
step or tamoxifen resistant and in these
patients what we identified is that
other m2x mRNA or expression level was
significantly higher in the patient and
resistant and if you click currently
survival in the
estrogen receptor-positive patient
having higher high rm2 predicted the
lower survival and relaxed regression
free survival as well as lower overall
survival
meaning that RRM RRM two plays are
important in how patient respond to the
therapy so to do this further to study
this part that we know that our two
limits the benefits of tamoxifen we
immediately acquired resistance models
by taking NC of seven cells which is the
tamoxifen sensitive cell line treated
them with the appropriate doses of
tamoxifen in stepwise increasing manner
to to come to our drug torrent processed
ourselves and then expanded the proton
persister cells to resistant cell lines
and we made four different acquired cell
lines from four different estrogen
receptor sensitive cell lines and we
observed that these cell lines when they
become a quad resistant down regulate
the expression of classical estrogen
receptor alpha 66 and overexpressed on
rm2 so you can see over here if that are
going to is highly expressed in Japan
with stem cells indicated by chain so at
that time the interesting study that
came out which indicated that there is
not only classical estrogen receptor
that is present that is also a splice
variants of estrogen receptors such as
estrogen receptor alpha 46 and estrogen
receptor alpha 36 estrogen receptor
alpha 36 was mainly interesting because
it's splice variant it is made by
alternative splicing where the exon
seven and eight were not transcribed but
the 9 is transcribed and it had a lower
molecular weight so estrogen receptor
alpha 66 is the classical 66 kilo Dalton
molecular weight protein but is estrogen
alpha 36 is 36 molecular weight protein
the role of estrogen receptor alpha 36
was also determined that 808
dimerizes at the plasma membrane with
the estrogen with the growth factor
signaling and in presence of tamoxifen
these are known to try on that kinase
and Akt pathway and ultimately leads to
cell proliferation so we looked at our
estrogen receptor-positive and estrogen
receptor negative cell line so these
estrogen receptor positive cell lines
were mainly positive for estrogen
receptor alpha and only zr7 by one which
is the tamoxifen in sensitive cell line
had higher expression of two
interestingly these cells also handle
over expression of estrogen receptor
alpha 36 but the estrogen receptor
negative cell line had significant
higher expression of as alpha 36 and
higher expression of honorum 2
indicating that there might there is an
inverse relation between other M 2
expression with classical estrogen
receptor alpha but there is a direct
relation with the estrogen receptor
alpha 36 with 2 and probably because of
this when tamoxifen is present it causes
the cell proliferation and patient
because of having higher estrogen alpha
36 so to study this further we wanted to
see the changes molecular changes that
happen over a period of time and hence
we took pmc of seven cell lines and just
allow them to grow or treat them with
the 5 micro move of tamoxifen and what
you can see is having a high confluency
cells and treating them with the high
dose of tamoxifen most of the cells died
by the date 10
however by day 15 they are able to start
their cell cycle and they start doing
again and then we look at the molecular
changes that happens over here by the 15
they are able to grow and have higher
order and - meaning that they are
probably able to start the DNA synthesis
and ultimately the cell cycle if we look
at the corresponding change
estrogen receptor signaling classical
estrogen receptor alpha 66 goes down
whereas the estrogen alpha 36 which is
the which is responsible for diminishing
response of tamoxifen starts to come off
and these cells also have corresponding
increase in the growth factor signaling
such as EGFR and hired phospho art as
well as higher phosphor ekt activity in
them if you look at canonical and kabhi
signaling that is also increasing p65
phosphorylation and Welby component as
compared to C well so this indicates
that as the cells become quite resistant
they also regulate the activity as well
as then these cells have higher
expression of bcl-2 which is a classical
which is a classical entire box optic
gene and diminished response of a part
as well as gas phase nine signaling so
can we use this prior knowledge that we
acquired at iron to is helpful in
sensitizing the image resistant cells
which has higher akt and use that to
this design a strategy for abrogating
pod resistance and to do that we we look
at the molecular events that are
happening in mcf7 cells in schambach ii
resistant cells and emulsifies in the
resistant cells and we treat them with
dye dots so what we found is when we
treat them with the dye dots which is
the arrival nucleotide reductase
inhibitor we see that there is a down
regulation of our m2 correspondingly the
tamoxifen resistance cells displayed
please estrogen receptor alpha 66 and
increase estrogen receptor alpha 36
which is now reversed upon demo demo dye
dogs treatment in combination with
tamoxifen there was a reduction in EGFR
as well as her two signaling when we
treat them with dye dogs there was
reduction in NF kappa-b signaling as
well as
the expression and there was a
restoration or induction of berkeley
part and caspase-9 indicating that when
you treat them with die dogs when you
inhibit this Aragon to activity these
cells are now able to retain the term
classical tamoxifen response and undergo
cell death because there is a
restoration of estrogen receptor alpha
66 which is a classical drug target
quatrain oxygen so next we examined the
effect of the mono therapy on mcf7 cells
which are estrogen receptor positive and
are treated with tamoxifen as a single
agent what you can see over here is that
the at the 10 most of the cells die and
ultimately these cells are able to
survive the higher concentration of
tamoxifen and were able to treat these
cells with p die dogs you see that these
cells are not able to grow by the end of
day 15 and they don't grow at all by 30
and then you keep the tamoxifen
resistant cells which are already
growing in presence of oxygen to treat
them with dye dogs you see that these
cells also undergo massive cell death
and cell proliferation
this was also we found the similar is
3470 cell line which is also a certain
receptor and john ii sensitive cell
lines that the combination of dye box
prevents the emergence of resistance but
as well as it prevents the growth of
already acquired resistance cell so I
would like to summarize my desserts what
I've shown you is that the vendor cell
tumors a tamoxifen dependant am higher
expression of estrogen receptor alpha 66
and they have low rm2 when these cells
become a quad resistant they start to
upregulate there are two expression
these cells show diminished
second estrogen receptor alpha 66
expression and increased in estrogen
receptor alpha 36 expression these cells
also have higher growth factor and NF
Kappa B signaling suggesting that our M
2 is a very good target and should be
given in a combination therapy to
restore the sensitivity of the Tron and
this leads to our tumor regression and
increased human survival in the patient
so what I have described until now over
here is a preclinical tool of how and
why we should use the combination this
ones are very good rationale to prevent
the adaptive resistance as well as
restore the sensitivity and deepen the
responses in the patient but there are
as we know that if you look at a bigger
picture though there are various
hallmarks of cancer not only to genomic
driver but these tumors also have
classical classical hallmark of cancer
indicated over here and illustrated by
and there are various inhibitors that
are designed to act on each of these
individual whole not but however what
this suggests is that there is one humor
in there are combination of these events
that are going on so just giving a
single tripod it's not our single drug
therapy is not sufficient and the cells
will often adapt to rely on the other
other mechanisms and hence we should
actively use the combination therapy to
prevent this adaptation from happening
and in our lab we think these approaches
in terms of how we can use the
experimental approaches to target the
drug resistance and we design mainly
genomics tools so what today I told you
how we can use the transcription changes
or microarray or RNAi profiling data to
create to come to a combination therapy
we can also use the proteomic basis
approaches such as the words RP pasa
or ms based mass spectrometry based
studies to identify what proteomics
level changes are happening and also we
can use a oncological tools such as
struck screen to identify different
alternative and adaptive or drug targets
and ultimately this leads towards a
design of a combination therapy that we
can use to overcome the adaptive
resistance that is happening and in my
research I particularly use these
genomic tools or proteomics tools or
logical tools listed over here and we
have published in the journal so you use
them for your advantage or cite them if
you find it useful but coming back to
current approaches so the main
limitation why we see this translation
is limited from clinical discovery to
chemical transition is because if you
look at the current landscape of
clinical trials that are there are two
thousand six hundred sixty-nine clinical
trial going on for the targeted therapy
and for immunotherapy we have about 1218
clinical trials going on of these 1494
are the combination therapy trial so
this is the data of the clinical trials
that are registered between 2014 and
2015
and if you see majority of the clinical
trials are sponsored by
cadonia centers or cancer centers about
57 percent industry has very limited but
again the major rule and there is only
3% combination being fair trials are
sponsored by NIH and of those clinical
trials if we look 85% are between the
combination of very limited between
targeted industry are sponsoring most of
the trial but if you look at the new
data at the end most of the clinical
trial response
by a single company you might have two
targets that for which you don't have a
drugs in your pipeline so you need to
posture the collaboration but such two
company collaborations for doing the
combination child therapy is very
limited
there are many regulatory challenges and
logistic challenges to come up and to
have versatile clinical choice for this
combination therapy and hence we need a
better system a better system where we
have we can have the leading-edge
science where we can have the access to
the patient data as well as we identify
and integrate very well the preclinical
knowledge that is generated from
academic center as well as from industry
to come up with a rational combination
therapy and identify a potential
biomarker and enroll in the patient
based on are likely to benefit from the
combination therapy and hence the vision
is that this will this will highly
impact and lead to a potential company
partnership to have two jobs work in
tandem and have a longer therapeutic
benefit for the patient so this cause
for aggregate what I call is aggregating
actionable knowledge where scientists
clinical researcher position and patient
lead to a development of a rapid
learning system there we we can use our
truck I have no Hitler disease and
create efficient combination therapy to
generate better trials design a better
treatment generate and put guidelines
and ultimately lead to advantage in the
patient for curing the cancer so with
that I would like to say thank you and
give acknowledgement to all my team
members at UCSF and at the University of
the Pacific with whom I work in
collaboration and I thank you all for
your attention and I will be happy to
take any questions here is my email
address will be to email me if you have
much
thank you thank you dr. Shah for that
informative presentation I would also
like to think glabrous for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder dr. Shah will follow up
with any questions you've submitted via
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we'll see you next time
goodbye